you're listening to episode 19 of
storycast 21 i'm jane secker
in 2005 i traveled to california to
cover one of this century's most
infamous entertainment court cases
when michael jackson went on trial for
child abuse charges
this is not simply a story about michael
jackson
this is the story of what it took for a
global news organization like sky news
to report the trial to an international
audience of millions
this is michael jackson the trial of the
century
[Music]
it was on the 28th of february 2005 when
i was sent to santa maria in california
to cover the michael jackson trial
michael jackson was on trial because he
was facing really serious charges
charges of child abuse against a minor
and this was a 13 year old boy called
gavin arviso
there were a number of different parts
to the trial there was allegations of
molestation intoxicating a minor
conspiracy to extort and also child
abduction so they were
really serious charges
but he wasn't just the biggest pop star
in the world he was pretty much the
biggest star in the world and he was
still selling millions and millions of
records
but despite huge international interest
the judge wouldn't allow any cameras in
the court in fact armed guards have been
in place to ensure the media don't
intrude so in collaboration with
e-entertainment sky decided that they
would reconstruct key parts of the day
objection speculative lack of foundation
and irrelevant and quite frankly nothing
like this had been attempted before
this meant among other things hiring a
michael jackson lookalike
who was himself going to have to take
center stage in the world's biggest
courtroom drama
[Music]
in its first week this trial has already
brought many surprises and we've seen
more detailed images of michael
jackson's private life than anyone could
have imagined
[Music]
week's biggest mover up 13 notches from
number 29 to 16 from the number one
album in the usa
so to understand the magnitude of this
story
we need to remind you if you don't
already know who michael jackson was
[Music]
well he was born in 1958 in indiana
pretty poor family and he had a very
domineering controlling father who
helped groom and polish michael and his
brothers and sisters into singers and
performers he'd had a string of number
one hits as the lead singer for the
jackson 5 and the jacksons and as a solo
singer he'd been to the top with ben as
early as 1972.
so by 2005 he was the long-established
king of pop but there was also a history
of child abuse allegations which dated
back to the 1990s the 93 investigation
came after another young boy geordie
chandler made similar abuse allegations
michael jackson settled that case out of
court for 10 million pounds now he was
facing these charges of abuse against a
minor again this was gavin arviso and
these charges could have seen him put in
prison for 20 years if convicted the
credibility of the arviso family was at
the center of this because we weren't
allowed cameras at the end of every day
there would be a reconstruction of the
key evidence using
actors but speaking the words that were
spoken called verbatim
i had already been doing michael jackson
probably
14 years
but at this time it had all been
like live shows where i was singing and
dancing
when i was three years old
there was no mtv there was nothing like
that
and this guy named casey kasem used to
do the top 10 videos of every week
and then the bad album came out and i
was in school and everybody would come
up to me because i looked like him you
ain't bad you ain't bad
i thought you know what i might as well
you know take this what people have
always been saying put my dance skills
together
and actually try to do something with it
i was
16 17 when i started trying to do
michael jackson i lived in hollywood so
i would go up to his star
dress like him and i would kind of dance
but meantime mind you i was also working
at mcdonald's
all of a sudden this guy comes in and he
was all like hey are you the one who's
usually down there doing michael jackson
well i've got a show for you michael
jackson broke his leg it's in beijing
china where you go i'm like well i don't
actually do michael jackson
he said well i'll give you three
thousand dollars a week at the time i
was making four dollars an hour so i
said now i do michael jackson
[Music]
michael jackson's only made one
appearance so far when he turned himself
in to the santa barbara sheriff last
month i had just finished this movie
called date movie that i was in
and my business manager told me that
they were gonna do the recreation of the
michael jackson trial because there were
no cameras allowed
my name is richard johnson i was the
producer on the michael jackson
reconstructions
he's already surrendered his passport
posted a three million dollar bond and
been fingerprinted
this time initially we didn't really
have a sense of how the day-to-day was
going to work until we actually got to
los angeles
obviously we cast the main members of
the production
the audition
my very first one happened that some i
don't even know what you call it they
were like little
bungalows turned into like makeshift
offices
at these bungalows there was a line
wrapped all the way around the building
the parking lot was full
i ran into at least
another six seven michael jackson
impersonators that i knew
within minutes of just arriving
basically i read some
cards of some michael jackson's speech
that he had done
we kind of had a plan
it kind of hinged on
the stenographer
the person that sits in the court and
takes all the notes basically as she
kind of wrote up her notes at the end of
the day we'd get sent a copy
and we would use that to
select the bits that we wanted to use
so the transcripts would come down from
santa maria
the team would get them they'd find the
highlights what they wanted to represent
on the show
and then they would get it and then they
would put them on teleprompters
there was no script there was no
like practicing or running over lines
there was
here's what we're going to do here's it
on the screen now act
jackson acknowledges the crowd then
arrived arm-in-arm with his ever-present
mother
it was a very big deal i mean it was
dubbed the trial of the century
it was a global news story there was
huge international interest and of
course because we weren't allowed in
court the michael jackson the world was
seeing was his lookalike edward moss
the very first day on set was a little
awkward because that was my first time
meeting
the extras the people who played in the
the gallery area
and i remember the very first lunch
break people were
kind of glaring at me
almost as if the things they heard i had
done
i was really torn
in
how i was gonna move forward with this
because i had built my life around
doing michael jackson and
the man that i met and worked for and
been around
i knew what i personally thought
but
again it was up to those people in that
jury box what was going to come back
the arrival every day was one of the big
things for us as journalists because it
was the only footage we would get of
michael
it
jackson
always the same routine there'd be a
security vehicle that would pull up
first and then his large suv
then the door would be opened
and he would emerge and there'd be a
huge cheer from behind the railings
where the fans were and he used to sort
of go through the security airline
security style thing and he used to do
it with a bit of a flamboyant kind of
snap step he would sort of twirl around
as they as they scanned him down with
the handheld scanner and he was quite
sprightly but as the trial went on
his demeanor
changed and he was clearly clearly being
worn down by the charges against him in
the course of the trial in this legal
marathon another hurdle is out of the
way but the latest stage in the michael
jackson case could hardly have been
further removed from the circus that
took place when jackson first appeared
in court in january
the formal indictment how it would work
is we would watch all the news reports
during the day so we would understand
what the kind of the the big kind of key
bits were of the day so the things to
look out for this is a crucial stage in
the legal battle every day you were
doing like a mini casting in the morning
get them ready get them to wardrobe and
get them kind of in place for later on
the producers would be biting their
nails frantically because there was a
couple of countries that i think it
actually broadcasted live
they'd run and get their highlights what
they wanted and all of a sudden the
whole tone
of everybody changed like
friends who were friends weren't friends
anymore people would be like in their
zone trying to get ready for their
things so
we knew there was a couple people you
didn't talk to because if you said
something to them they'd be agitated
because they'd want to be you know
getting it right
the first time you might be
reading something is when it'd be on the
teleprompter did you ever have a
conversation with mark schaffel about
janet arvizo objection foundation
argumentative overruled but the day that
really got me off guard was the day that
he
didn't show up to court and he was
running late
and then all of a sudden he shows up in
pajamas his legal team had said he was
unwell and he wasn't going to turn up
and the judge basically said he is
coming bring him here
i didn't own any pajamas let alone
pajamas for a grown man with trains on
them here's what the jurors heard
according and i found these little train
appliques
and i they were iron on so i ironed them
on to these blue pajamas and they're on
a blazer and i
i was almost late that day with hair and
makeup because trying to put those
pajama pants together
i think some people might think oh it's
it's actually a bit salacious doing
something like this but actually because
we weren't allowed cameras there was a
clear public interest to correctly
and at length and contemporaneously
explain what was happening inside the
court
i mean his nose in particular looked
really strange someone said to me they
thought that maybe there was the end of
his nose was actually missing and it
looked like it had been
sort of
rebuilt every day with some kind of
plasticky sort of substance like
plasticine or something and it would be
literally a different shape every day
but you know this was further on in the
trial and he was very very frail and he
physically had to be helped into the
courtroom and of course there was a
global audience watching you know
hundreds of millions
from his undignified arrest to his daily
body search this trial has proved to be
michael jackson's toughest ever
appearance on the world stage
i had never given up working at michael
jackson's star on hollywood boulevard
there was no middle ground either people
loved him
and stood by him
or they fully believed that he had done
it and
i would get called all kinds of names
throughout it all the master of south
mythology has maintained his innocence i
saw people from germany or japan
fighting amongst each other because
somebody would say something rude to me
now living in a secret address in los
angeles i had actually seen a couple of
physical altercations because
people like somebody supporting me and
somebody
not supporting what i was doing
seen that at least three different times
out there
because tourists
were at odds about michael jackson
so two weeks pass and then a month and
then two months and finally after three
months of evidence we arrive at the day
of the verdict
i think nobody really knew who the jury
would believe
did he say that this woman told him she
wanted money i think he said uh
he thinks she wants money did you ask
him no obviously i was
aware of
the fact that
it would have an impact on
eddie's career because effectively he
would he made a living being michael
jackson
you know his life's going to change
dramatically whatever happens
i was very nervous because
even if people had one new me i didn't
know if it was something i could still
do
like walking into a show and not know
how the fans were gonna react or not
fans if i were doing a nightclub if
somebody didn't appreciate me being
there was i going to be in danger you
know i didn't know
if it was something i still wanted to
pursue even myself
we're stopped thinking what's going to
happen what's going to happen and then
obviously right the jury's coming
everyone kind of scrambles and gets
ready
not only did i breathe because
he was found not guilty and i felt that
i was gonna be okay but i could actually
relax for a minute
then there's obviously the bit where the
lady was releasing the doves
as each count was being read out
and we spoke to people in the court and
some of them could sort of see what was
going on
and then we had to sort of discuss how
we were going to shoot it because
obviously there was no
dialogue
jackson didn't speak
michael jackson
as far as in the courtroom never said
one word
there was a couple of days that
i heard that he was laughing and
pointing and
looking very cocky and confident so i
had to pull that out to when i thought
it was
but other than that he never he never
was on the stand he never did anything
i didn't ever get to say anything
it was strange to do
one story for four months
you do do it with court cases
but you often would do other stories in
between you wouldn't necessarily be
doing it every single day
but we did it in an innovative way the
public wanted to know what was happening
and they were tuning in to these
reconstruction shows daily but to talk
about nothing but michael jackson for
four months was a little bit
extraordinary and i was quite pleased
when i came home not to have to talk
about him ever again
the fact that the sort of production
became
a bigger thing than we ever envisaged it
would be as well
i guess that's that sort of thing's a
bit it's a bit out of your hands and
it's more it's more luck than anything
else but yeah i'm definitely proud to
have been involved in it for sure
jackson himself remains hidden behind
the walls of neverland he's said to be
planning a party this week for family
after the trial it's also reported that
his arraignment it actually heightened
my career because
not only again 82 countries giving you
and being in gq magazine and time
magazine and all these things i mean i
went from edward moss to edward moss
i mean i was the most sought out michael
jackson impersonator for the next
almost 15 years
[Music]
whether as villain or star jackson draws
the crowds the public gallery is always
full his lawyers have been busy pumping
out doubts about the prosecution
if anybody doesn't think that the true
motivation of these charges and these
allegations
[Music]
in 2009 michael jackson died from a
cardiac arrest he was 50.
in the years since his death further
allegations of child abuse involving
other minors have emerged michael
jackson's estate has vehemently denied
these allegations the singer was never
found guilty of any charges of child
abuse
eddie moss continues to live in
california he continued to make a living
playing michael jackson until the covert
19 pandemic in 2020.
michael jackson the trial of the century
was written and produced by rob mulhern
with me jane secker for more information
go to skynews.com forward slash
storycast 21.
next time
what essentially this was was a stunt by
the queen
she herself had decided to do this and
she was participating in it along with
an a-list hollywood actor daniel craig
who was basically james bond this figure
of what is known around the world as the
great british character in film
[Music]
[Music]
you